that we are going live so if you want to
just
retweet and then people might be able to
join us
in the uh in the chat room that would be
great
and i'm going to put it on facebook too
and let's see if we have any viewers
here
we are live i don't see any viewers
yet but uh sometimes it takes a little
while for the viewers to show up
and uh hopefully we will get this all
set up
great so how is everything there's a
powerful thunderstorm
going on in the pacific northwest i hope
you're okay
yeah no it looks everything's fine but
we just had a few little like glitches
in our wi-fi and it seemed
better to come to campus yeah well you
made it remarkably fast so i salute you
for that that's uh
that's fantastic uh yep great
uh so let me get see we got some viewers
coming and trickling in hello everybody
out there
uh it's such a treat to have uh emily
levesque here i've been practicing your
name for the last month emily it's
i want to say levesqueue but then again
i always like to say
epitome and uh
all sorts of other neologisms as they
say
uh how are you doing today otherwise
emily
doing well how about you pretty good
yeah we
we have a couple of clouds in the sky so
it's not perfect
southern california weather uh but but
we'll survive
you know i actually miss the
thunderstorms but be careful
be careful what you wish for for what
you wish yeah
your picture there i'd rather have my
audience look at you so there you are
there's professor emily levesque
of the university of washington
astronomy department i've followed your
career for a long time
and it's only because of twitter that we
met which is kind of silly because
i actually have uh my uh my
editor at norton for losing the nobel
prize
uh was none other than your agent i
believe which is jeff shreeve
so jeff if you're out there uh thank you
for not making the introduction to me
emily i i only asked him a hundred times
but
uh but i had to go right to you jeff's
been pretty busy these days with it's
been quite a time in the publishing
industry so
yeah i imagine yeah for me i've called
this pandemic podcasting because there's
almost no way i'd be able to get great
guests like you and others
if there wasn't a pandemic going on so
i'm really appreciative of your time
and uh so i have a bunch of questions uh
for you
and i'm also gonna take uh questions
from the audience but i want to get
started
with a poem and this poem i want to get
your reaction to
and it's called when i heard the learned
astronomer
by walter whitman okay here it goes
not too long i'll read it really quickly
i speak i'm a new yorker so i can speak
pretty quickly
when i heard the learned astronomer when
the proofs the figures were ranged in
columns
before me when i was shown the charts
and diagrams to add divide and measure
them
when i sitting heard the astronomer when
he lectured
with much applause in the lecture room
how soon unaccountable
i became tired and sick till rising and
gliding out
i wandered off by myself in the mystical
moist night air and from time to time
looked up in perfect silence at the
stars
so romantic uh besides the you know the
male astronomer making him sick
uh what do you how do you react to this
uh to this uh
very well-known poem emily i've i'm
familiar with the poem i have a bit of a
bone to pick with walt whitman and part
of it
he is you know a starting point but i
actually
it gets out one of the fundamental
things that i wanted to address in the
last star gazers because there's this
conception in science that by breaking
something down into the nuts and bolts
and the zeros and ones and the physics
that we lose the beauty of it and we
lose the ability to appreciate it
and to me i feel like nothing could be
further from
the truth i i love looking up at the
stars and thinking oh god i know why
betelgeuse is red i
know why that nebula is sitting where it
is
and i interviewed more than 100 other
astronomers for the last stargazers and
i think
to a person everybody still had that
sense of wonder to some degree about
what they were studying
in the sky i mean i tell a story in the
book about a bunch of us looking through
a telescope and looking through an
eyepiece in a large telescope which is
rarer than you might think
for professional astronomers and we all
sounded like
eight-year-olds looking at saturn for
the first time and these are people that
have
absolutely dug into the physics of the
things we're looking at we've probably
cursed our laptops and computer code
that have
prevented us from you know working
properly and understanding these things
and at the same time we're just in love
with what we see so i think whitman
missed the mark a little bit
i gotta say yeah me too i always feel
like
it's so romantic to think about this in
a as a poet
and then i actually was honored to teach
a class with a
pulitzer prize-winning poet friend of
mine ray armentrout
and she and i co-taught a class called
poetry for physicist
because it's my feeling and i want to
get your reaction to it as a
communicator of science
that we scientists have an obligation
that we should actually be
forced under penalty of law no we
shouldn't be we
we have enough of that as uh state
university employees the two of us
um but we should uh take as much
training or some amount of training
maybe not as much but
we should dedicate some attention to the
teaching
of our craft of what we do and of the
wonders of what we discover not only
because the people pay us in their taxes
because it's almost a moral obligation
in my opinion to share this wondrous
material that we have
as you do so lovingly tenderly in the
book uh with the public what say you
about uh the obligation of a scientist
to
to almost be forced not just because you
have to put in your grant but that we
have an obligation a moral obligation to
teach to the public
who are not experts in about the wonders
of astronomy
i think it's a crucial part of what we
do and
you hit on part of it which is that
people's we're fortunate that people's
tax dollars support a lot of our
research and
i think there's something fair to say
you know we want to show you what
you're paying for and you want to we
want to show you what you're doing i
also like to me it's a big part of why i
got into this my absolute favorite thing
to do is to get someone else excited
about science
and get someone else excited about
astronomy and being able to just go up
to somebody and say did you know this
this is so
cool is such a valuable part of what we
do and i think that being able to
communicate
to honestly to communicate at all levels
to communicate to the public and even to
communicate
to each other is a key part of science
um a point that i make to a lot of my
students when they get um
i've had students in classrooms who are
a little put off by
writing and emphasis on writing and they
kind of say well i became a scientist
because i'm not
super into writing and the point i try
to make is if einstein couldn't have
properly explained
general relativity nobody would have
cared it wouldn't have been
rev it wouldn't have been you know
regarded as this groundbreaking science
because you have to be able to
communicate it
and whether it's communicating to peers
or the public
or reporters or grant officers it's the
same
basic thing you have to be able to tell
the story and you have to be able to
explain why what you're doing matters
and
in that explanation process i think it's
uh critically important
to really recognize that we are given
this great gift which
is the uh which is the source material
that we have i always say
human beings are born with two
refracting telescopes in the middle of
our heads
and uh we should make use of that and
it's not maybe a surprise that that most
people find astronomy the most kind of
uh appealing of all the sciences i
always joke nobody
looks up at the sky and says i hate that
republican constellation over there
that democratic comets really annoying
me
it's apolitical it's sort of a safe
space but it's an intellectual space
and the the question that i always you
know encounter is
why aren't we doing a better job at
communicating it and i think
writing books as you've done in popular
books goes a long way and so i want to
commend you for the last star gazers
we're going to spend a lot of time
today talking about that i want people
to put it in the
their questions for emily uh in the in
the chat and some are already
uh trickling in and that's gonna be
great uh first of all i
always judge books by their covers uh i
don't know about you
i always heard this uh this argument oh
you know don't judge a book by its cover
but then as you know they put a lot of
effort money time
into cover design cover art yours is
unique
in that i haven't seen it has this
beautiful three-dimensional
i'll take this apart but you actually
have two covers you've got an inner
cover and an outer cover and
both are so delicious and delightful
tell us how did you get the
idea for the title of the book the
subtitle of the book and the cover
design
well i'll start with the cover design
because i unfortunately can't take a lot
of credit for that um that was
down to the brilliant design and artists
um
the artistic team at sourcebooks which
is my publisher
but i did get really excited when they
showed me the cover
because they sent me the mock-up and i
had had like a
sad little like powerpoint slide mock-up
of what i thought the cover was gonna be
and i drew it the way most astronomy
books are drawn there's sort of a black
background with stars and like a
silhouette of someone looking up
and when they sent me the cover and it
was almost black and white i was
surprised for half a second and then
realized it's wonderful because it makes
it stand out
and that comparison of the black and
white sort of almost line drawing of the
galaxy
and then when you peel off the jacket
that beautiful star field
actually i thought was brilliant
regarding the book because it's a little
pictorial representation of how
astronomy's changed that the front of
the book
almost looks like a photographic plate
so those
black-on-white images that astronomers
used to take
using glass plates that were treated to
react to light
and then that little window through into
the star field and peeling off the cover
gives you that you know riot of color
image that we
imagine when we think of a hubble image
today and
that also actually ties into where the
title of the book came from
because i've had some people sort of
call me out and say well the title
sounds depressing and it's meant to be a
little bit more of a challenge than
something sad
um it's in part a reference to the way
technology is changing astronomy
so the way that people did astronomy
back when we used photographic plates
is very different than the way you and i
do it today and the way that we do
astronomy is different than the way our
students
are learning astronomy so we used to
literally be attached to the telescope
in some cases and now maybe we
observe from a room next to a telescope
or a remote operating room
some telescopes don't need operators
anymore at all so
it's a really exciting time for science
but it's also removing astronomers from
where we used to be
in the observing process and i wanted to
write a book that saved those
stories from when observing was really
hands-on
and then the challenge of it is that
people obviously do still
stargaze i hope someone looks at that
title and says wait i stargaze i like
stargazing a lot what do you mean
and people will stargaze for their jobs
or for the pleasure of it
and i think that recognizing the kind of
curiosity and enthusiasm behind
why people stargaze is really valuable
so that was another
sort of call out that i wanted to make
in the title that the reasons
behind stargazing really drive what we
do even though the way we do our work is
very different these days yeah it's a
lyrical book it's a it's sort of a you
know kind of a poetic book and it's in
its way
and that title is suggestive of this
longiness
uh longing for perhaps the darkness of
the night sky in ancient
i don't think anyone wants to go back
and ride inside a telescope again
uh as as you depict in the book or you
know possibly be
threatened by gunshots from a irate
graduate student in texas uh but that
really uh reminds me that the book is
mostly it's kind of a memoir it's sort
of an adventure story
and i want i hate it when podcasters
would ask me
explain your entire book so that nobody
has to read it and nobody buys it
so i i want to take through some slides
that we have that you've provided maybe
you know you can sort of follow along
with it but i i wanted to start with
kind of misconceptions about astronomy
uh because you've got a couple are
misconceptions about science and how you
got interested in science maybe you'll
take us through that
uh your childhood certainly you smash
the mold of the mit
nerd you know i always joke how do you
know someone went to mit
well they and they're outgoing well they
look at your shoes when they talk to you
instead of their own
i've used that joke too many times to to
really uh
keep keep using it in good faith but
talk us through your early childhood
how you young emily growing up outside
of uh
boston area ended up going to mit and
uh and meeting friends such as uh
friends of the show like uh professor
frank wilczyk who's coming on the show
soon too to talk about his new book
and uh and others how did you get
interested in astronomy we cannot avoid
that topic
so i really was interested in astronomy
from the time that i was tiny
and in the slides i think we have
photographic evidence yes
this is true i'm going to share the
screen on one side
so i'll share this but yes i'm sure look
i'm showing the side with contact right
now
just so you know there you are there's a
you with two uh astronomers looking
through telescopes apparently with lab
coats on
as we all wear um yes so
um there's i'm not sure if um viewers
can see these
slides because i can't see on skype what
we're seeing but there's a photo of me
sporting a little hubble space
telescope's t-shirts i'm about six years
old
my brother describes that facial
expression as what do you mean
six-year-olds can't use hubble
um because i look like i'm just raring
to get my hands on the telescope
but um i really did get interested from
a very young age and i come from a
family of people who are not
professional scientists
but who are scientists by nature who are
very curious who really encourage
curiosity
and all of that really helps feed into
sort of sparking that seed from very
early on
so i tell the exact story of when i
started to get interested in astronomy
in the book
but it sort of stuck the whole time that
i was growing up
people would ask what i wanted to do and
i'd say well i want to be a ballerina or
an astronomer
or i want to be a firefighter or an
astronomer or a violinist
or an astronomer and then when i got to
college and got to mit
i got the chance to start taking physics
classes for the first time which were
exhaustingly hard um frank welchek was
an amazing
um freshman mechanics professor um
that's quite a person to be learning
sort of physics 101 from
but it was a trial by fire lesson in
getting brought up to speed on physics
and then i got to take my first
observing class from the
amazing jim elliott who is just a
legend in the field i would learn later
for the incredible observing that he's
done but from him i learned you know
the first best practices of how to use a
telescope i learned that we put
telescopes in the back of planes
and then fly with them up into the
stratosphere um he
took me out to lowell observatory in
flagstaff for the first time with the
rest of the class
which is where i met collaborators that
i still work with today so
it was a wonderful introduction through
kind of the nuts and bolts of observing
and the adventure of observing
yeah we show some pictures of you also
uh the the telescope's kit peek and and
then of course the movies that uh
feature
heavily in your upbringing at least the
movie contact
especially looming large another friend
of the show jill tarter
uh who's uh who's an amazing astronomer
and uh and spans the wavelength range
that you describe in the book
and i think you know one of the most
interesting things about my book about
my book about your book is wishful
thinking and my part you know that's the
that's the highest praise you can give i
wish it was i wish i wrote your book
um but uh but you cover all sorts of uh
astronomical techniques technologies etc
uh observations that
contact features with uh jody foster
playing our friend jill tarter
all the way up through you know ultra
high energy even all ultraviolet and
beyond
neutrino telescopes gravitational wave
telescopes which are in the news almost
always
so i want to get your reaction uh since
we are um
uh kind of it's still in the afterglow
of nobel prize annunciation season
what uh how does how does the discovery
of black holes
and or at least the compact objects
they're very careful not to say that
we've discovered black holes necessarily
but
compact objects as viewed by both the
event horizon telescope which you talk
about a little bit
but also andrea guez's work up the road
for me
in uh in at the university of california
los angeles
what uh how they've impacted the study
of gravitational waves in particular
as well as optical techniques how
they've influenced astronomy now
with these modern techniques and tools
yeah it's it's a really fun question to
pose because i was recently um working
on another project where i was sort of
writing through the history of
compact objects in black holes and i
always like tracing it back to jocelyn
bell
and the discovery of the first pulsar so
the first neutron star
these bizarre stars that are supported
by principles of quantum physics
and those had sparked a lot of interest
in black holes
and compact objects in general and then
you had early observations of black
holes that actually came through
suborbital rocket observations um people
were launching x-ray detectors on
rockets and picking up x-rays from
a black hole that we now know i believe
cygnus x1 was one of the first ones
that got picked up so looking at the
progression from those early discoveries
through to gravitational wave
observatories and the awesome research
that
won the nobel prize very recently um i'm
sure everybody saw those animations
of the um the stars going around the
supermassive black hole the center of
our galaxy and i show those in class all
the time
but i like the idea of putting side by
side
the science and the amazing stuff that
we found
was studying black holes or studying the
center of our galaxy or
with the um image that eht got and then
putting that alongside the
adventures that people had trying to do
these observations
um i write in the last star gazers about
rocket based astronomy
and how ridiculous it is to try and
build this you know beautiful perfect
instrument and then just
stick it on something and set it on fire
like really um
and then you look at the amazing image
of a black hole from the eht
and hear about how hard the team members
had to work
to get that image and the months of
observations
and even something like shipping the
data back from the south pole
to cambridge was this like months long
saga and
i like putting the two side by side
because you get the fascinating science
but you get the sort of human faces in
the human story
alongside it and like maybe not
everybody works on black holes but
everybody can understand the little
quirks of a difficult work day
and hopefully that helps make it all
seem a little more real and a little
more present
to readers absolutely yeah it's so much
fun to look at it and
actually right now where i am is as a
location at least one of the
uh one of the the uh characters in your
book who's very much
a real person unfortunately she passed
away in april was margaret burbidge
who is my late great colleague at
university of california san diego
and she actually helped to found the
astronomy group that i'm sitting within
right now and i'm actually in
her late husband jeff uh at burbridge's
office right now
and uh i'm honored to have his office he
was a real character
and it was funny because as you
described in the book margaret who
was one of the foremost astronomers of
all time
she was not able to actually do her
craft as she had been trained
because of essentially sexism that
prevailed back in the 60s and 70s
and it's so interesting that he would
get time on the telescope
at mount wilson even though he was a
theorist and i almost never let
theorists into my laboratory let alone
near a telescope and sitting in the
telescope to guide it actually one time
according to margaret he almost died he
almost got crushed to death
inside of i think it was the mcdonald
observatory but one of the treats i get
is kind of mentioned in your book which
is i find these photographic glass
plates this is one from 1971 this is
before i was born
excellent uh and i find them this is
from sarah tololo this is from a
sensitometer which i
don't even know what that means but and
this is a test plate but i'll find ones
of galaxies
behind my desk over here is a image of
m82 i believe it is
uh which uh it's jet shooting out uh so
famously there it is
i'll put it there it is uh and uh and i
find all these other objects here
of course we had margaret uh um a
burbidge here as well as sally ride
uh maria geppert mayer who is also in
the shot there she goes
um so we've had a great tradition of
astronomers especially female
astronomers at uc san diego
what's the status now of women in
astronomy how is it getting better
you know uh and and it's refreshing to
get your perspective i think you give an
honest appraisal you're not
pollyannish about it but you're also
accurate about it we need to improve
where is it uh what is the status of
women in astronomy from your perspective
as a professional astronomer
i mean i've been it's funny to think
about this because i think of myself as
very fortunate
in my career in that i've had very
supportive colleagues i've had
a lot of positive experiences in
astronomy but that shouldn't be
fortunate that should be the norm
um things have improved a great deal
since margaret burbidge
what had to um observe as jeff's
assistant
um and i talked a little bit about sort
of the
math and statistics on this in the book
um
in 2017 women earned 40
of astronomy phds so there are certainly
more women entering the field and i
think what we are now rightfully
focusing on in the field is keeping
women in the field keeping women
supported recognizing
amazing researchers like andrea guezz um
she was the first woman
astronomer to win the nobel prize and
when you think about the
many fantastic women who've done
research that just completely changed
and shaped the field
it's wonderful that she got this
recognition and it's also so
sad that she was the first and not the
10th given how many people are doing
this work so
the support to keep women in the field
and to recognize their contributions are
important
and there's a lot of other axes we need
to consider because
women got 40 of doctoral degrees awarded
in 2017
but hispanic women were four percent
african-american women
were two percent and being able to
encourage more people to enter the field
and then support them to stay
and to want to be a part of this
community is one just the right thing to
do as people
and it's really important for the
science
um you described astronomy a little
earlier as a political and there's this
nice feeling of looking up at the stars
and not seeing
a political affiliation when you look at
a constellation
and i think that that would be the dream
that you get to
leave politics and human matters behind
but astronomy is done
by people and when there are political
issues that
are keeping people from being full
participants and being able to
really dig into and love this field i
think that it's an important part of the
field to try and
keep that at bay or to fix those
problems and to listen to our colleagues
who are telling us what they need
to do the really amazing science that
they're capable of doing
yeah that's a refreshing part of your
book that you don't sugarcoat it you
don't say that you know everything is
great now and we've made all these
struts
uh we're moving in the in the right
direction there there are you know
certainly a positive
first derivative but but i think you
know the future will
will tell i also was very moved to
uh to both see the uh renaming
of the veer ruben tells observatory from
the
lsst i didn't i never thought that was a
good name anyway
but uh who better to name it for so i
wonder if you can talk about that she
was one of the
also star gazers who made their way
through uc san diego
and actually she did some of her first
rotation curve work with uh with
margaret and jeff's
burbidge's help and actually credits
them uh for believing in her
and and of course many of us were deeply
saddened by her passing without
recognition that she's so
richly deserved so um so in terms of
that the nancy
rowan space telescope that's going to be
launched um the the progress seems to be
uh seems to be happening but you're
right there needs to be more work
and um i wonder you know from your
perspective i hate you know i asked
katie mac this when she was on my pod
you know how do we get more on
girls and interested in science and she
said you know well don't just give them
pink circuit boards you know
let's do something real something
tangible um and so
you know you got exposed to it and it
seems to me that it could be
done through almost anybody um you know
a parent with with very
little you know a few resources even um
the way that you got your exposure was
with a tiny little telescope and
interested parents and
and i wonder is that unique to you or
your parents just exceptional or
in that sense your brother etc uh kind
of wanting to outdo your brother which
is
i i get that i've got an older brother
too um oh i still aspire to be like him
that's
you know that's what happens whenever we
have a big city yeah it's just you're
just a professor at one of the best
universities in the whole world you know
you're really you're really a slacker
emma you know
yeah so go outside gotta keep working on
it um but
so i mean my family was a wonderful
aspect of this but i don't
i hope that that doesn't make me too
unusual um
i actually always get a kick out of this
framing when people say how do we get
more girls
interested in science i didn't need any
convincing
to be interested in science i don't
think your average eight-year-old needs
any convincing that black holes are cool
whenever i give a presentation
at a planetarium all my questions are
from eight-year-olds
any gender and they're all about black
holes so we don't need to convince kids
that science is interesting we need to
convince them to stay in it and we need
to convince them that it's something
they can do
that they can see themselves in it as a
career that it's something they can
pursue
so i never think of it as how to get
girls interested in science it's partly
how to keep girls interested and how to
make science a place for them
um so yeah the pink the pink circuit
boards really won't do it
um i think it's just recognizing you
know science is awesome and we need to
kind of
in my mind i'd like to see gender
separated from what you can or can't do
or how we need to treat you
um i think something nice that my family
did for me as a whole is i was never
once told
oh it's so good that a girl is
interested in science and
oh isn't it nice that you're a little
girl that likes you know dolls
and space it was just like yeah you're a
kid that likes space and you like
dolls and you like running around in the
backyard
and it was never something sort of
specially
presented because of my gender so when i
looked for role models
i didn't parse my role models by gender
i very much parsed
them by oh look at somebody else who's
as geekily interested in science
as me um looking back it was especially
meaningful when i saw other
nerdy girls like me who were you know
featured as
scientists or featured as people who did
the sort of work i wanted to do
but i think that i didn't need to be
talked into science i needed to be
talked into knowing that that was a
place i could
go and be and be happy yeah in my
opinion though i i feel like it's
uh it's basically child abuse if you
don't get your kid a little fifty dollar
telescope and
and put him outside at least put a let
you know
him or her look up at the at the moon
because you can see the exact same
craters that galileo saw on the moon you
can see the same phases of
venus and and the rings of saturn and ju
and the moons of jupiter
that all and it doesn't cost very much
and look in your case in my case it led
to a career in astronomy
uh and a very lucrative one at that i'm
sure
i swear by but not for what it's worth i
swear by binoculars as a tool
yeah and you can get those from anywhere
because not everybody might have a
backyard not everybody might have a dark
sky
to admire but a pair of binoculars and
just pointing them even from like a
city corner up at the moon is already
fascinating um
as i interviewed people for the last
star gazers i never asked anybody why
did you become
right an astronomer because i wasn't
looking at origin stories i wanted to
hear about like their adventures once
they were in the field
almost everybody told me anyway because
they were all observing stories and
it was oh i got to go camping with my
family when i was little and i got to
see a dark sky
or i grew up in the city i never saw
stars and then i went to a planetarium
show and my mind was just blown
but it was always some moment of seeing
the sky and just going like
wow so the more you can give people that
chance to kind of get hooked i think the
better it is
and not see those darn learned
astronomers get them out of here
uh they'll make the kids sick so i have
a question from
the audience and this question uh
questioner's name is
um i think it is sinbad
simbad simran sorry simran and uh he or
she is asking is dark matter
research the future forte for the
upcoming generation of physicists and
astronomers how long will it last
and has it begun full fledgedly this is
looking for for
dark matter specifically
oh interesting um so i'm my research
specialty isn't dark matter and i think
if you try to map like all the exciting
fields that are coming up in astronomy
we'd be here all day
um you can think about all the amazing
stuff we're gonna learn just about how
stars work which is what i do research
um searching for exoplanets searching
for planets that could have life on them
but i think the study of dark matter has
been
an amazing subfield since vera rubin's
early work
and i think some of the telescopes that
we have coming online so
everything from the reuben observatory
which is going to look at how the sky is
changing with time
to james webb and nancy roman so these
amazing infrared telescopes they're all
going to help give us new pieces of the
puzzle
um and there's also people that work
very much on the sort of laboratory and
physics side of it
trying to get at dark matter on a sort
of particle level
so i think it's definitely a really
exciting
future field in astronomy i'm biased
because i work on stars but i don't
think it's
the most the only exciting future field
but it's one of those areas where the
technology and the new telescopes that
we're building
really helps shapes the science that
we're going to be able to do and dark
matter isn't a great place for that
going forward
yeah i'm showing on the on the um live
stream
um uh screen share that you can't see uh
the image you sent me from your
colleague julia de canton's
uh fat survey was that the pen traumatic
well what does it stand for you tell me
oh um oh gosh panchromatic
hubble andromeda treasury survey i think
you know it's a great acronym yeah
that's right
oh we could do a whole i'm i'm not sure
if you've done this you could do a whole
podcast on just tortured astronomical
acronyms i don't know
why astronomers in particular do this i
think it's because i think it's best to
get into astronomy you have to be a
little bit of an
art or creative kid but boy we have some
wacky acronyms
but yeah this don't talk to me about
that i i coined the term biceps right
right but so this is this amazing
multi-color survey
of andromeda and i actually like showing
it to people as a contrast between
the hubble image of andromeda i think on
the previous slide
taken by edwin hubble with the glass
photographic plate and this was the
plate in which
he conclusively determined that
andromeda was another galaxy
rather than just this weird spiral
shaped nebula in our own
milky way and then you compare that to
the hubble image that we have today and
it's just a great demonstration
of the way technology has really opened
up our eyes and changed what we also
have technology has very much changed
how we get data right yeah i'm comparing
yeah
exactly and then the future with the
vera ribbon observatory that you combine
in this uh in the slideshow here uh just
the
a massive amount of technology imaging
you talk about
the equivalent number of lord of the
rings dvds you you'd be getting in a
single
day a night of observing it's just
incomprehensible
i have another guest uh who's got a name
which which must be
maybe it's an irish name i don't know
church of entropy
this is the name that she is showing
here does
uh does emily believe in singularities
so in other words i i've been talking a
lot about
the the absence of really physical
evidence for singularities and that
we um we have evidence for compact
objects but
there's no evidence at least in my to my
knowledge maybe you can correct me
but of an actual infinite quantity such
as density temperature
pressure whatever in the physical world
in the mathematical world certainly it
does exist but
um do you believe that that
singularities can truly exist in
in space and then in time so
with the caveat that this isn't my
research specialty i
do mostly because i like the i we do see
an example of something infinite we have
an infinite universe
and i like the idea of an infinite
universe and physics in an infinite
universe basically being mathematics
come to life
now whether one of these is common
like garden variety and something that
we see all the time and exactly how you
get into the nuts and bolts of what
happens to physics around something that
we might call
a singularity gets into a whole other
topic and a topic that i can't pretend
to be an expert on
but i see it as a very elegant
mathematical and physical explanation of
phenomena that we
see when we're talking about black holes
and when we're talking about
these great extremes of how space-time
works so
when it gets into exactly what you would
call a singularity and
exactly where we think the mathematics
and the physics
either meet in the middle or kind of
pass each other a little bit i'm not
sure but
i like it very much as the clearest
explanation for how compact objects and
especially black holes
how they actually work and then getting
a little bit closer
to uh to home perhaps you speak a lot
and i actually was not familiar with
this but speaking of
of singularities and people that have
worked on this the thorn
uh zeitgow object you spend a lot of
time on that it's so fascinating
what appeals to you about about this
object or why should people care about
such an object i'm showing the image of
it
on the screen right now you can't see it
unfortunately but
talk to us about the thorns
so i had to email anna zhitkov to make
sure that i was pronouncing it right
it's the object but um i got fascinated
in these because one of my research
specialties are stars known as red
supergiants
so these are stars that are much more
massive than our
sun that um live these very short lives
and then die as a supernova
um and a thornjitov object is thought to
look almost exactly like a red
supergiant
except instead of a core that supports
itself through nuclear fusion
that's a core that supports itself
through quantum physics because its core
is a neutron star um kiplorn and
anazidkov predicted these back in the
1970s
and for decades they were kind of a
consequence of this infinite universe
idea right if physics says that these
can
exist they either should exist or they
don't because the physics is wrong
but finding them and looking for
evidence of them was pretty challenging
um i started working on this with a
colleague of mine
after ana zhitkov emailed us saying you
know you work on red super giants
have you thought about trying to search
for these they're very hard to find
because you mostly need to identify them
based on really weird tiny chemical
quirks but we undertook a search for
them as part of my
research and i talk about that search
and what we found
and how we found it in the last
stargazers because
to me it's a fun comparison of how
people imagine
scientific discovery works you know like
you sit at a telescope a big red light
goes off and you leap up like eureka we
found aliens
as opposed to how it actually wound up
working out
but i think they're fascinating because
if they if we truly have found the first
one and we're still studying
these stars then it's a completely new
model for how stars can work and the
physics of the insides of stars
and understanding the physics of the
insides of stars helps us understand
supernovae it helps us understand things
like core collapse
and compact objects in black holes it
helps us understand
the composition of the universe which is
what margaret burbidge worked on
so there's a lot of puzzles to pull out
of something like a new way for a star
to work
yeah and so my audience
members are wondering about how you
have used a multi-wavelength
capabilities are you going to use
ligo for anything in particular ice
cubes some of the
instruments you talk about in the book
i actually love the idea of
multi-wavelength astronomy and it's
something that's becoming more and more
prevalent that instead of
picking a wavelength regime on a paper
that we just submitted
talking about gravitational waves and
the idea of using gravitational waves to
study thorndikov objects so i would love
to use ligo data at some point
i've worked a lot with optical and
infrared data with i've gotten hubble
time to use ultraviolet data
i've had research students work with
x-ray data
um i think i've worked across pretty
much the whole electromagnetic spectrum
i'd love to do more work in the radio
um that's probably my least well sampled
area but
i think multi-wavelength and
multi-messenger astronomy is just
amazing um a point that i try to make to
readers in the last stargazers is that
we don't for the most part get labs
um unless you're an asteroid specialist
in your research very literally
comes to you um all you have to work
with is light
so the more light we can get and the
more data that we can get to try and
answer our questions the
closer we get to having a lab and the
closer we get to having things that we
can tinker with
so more wavelengths the better
more wavelength more better exactly uh
so the next question i have is about
these uh
peritons is that how you say it these
are interesting um
yes strange objects which also rely and
so
uh some evidence perhaps for
instrumental or systematic biases that
we've uh that we've observed
so can you say something about that i'm
showing the scenes from uh from parks
and from uh and the slide with a
microwave oven on my screen right now
oh yes so i i love the story of peritons
because people tend to get a kick out of
stories like this when you're
giving a presentation or talking to
people about science because
i think people like to hear about
scientists being tricked and i think any
good scientist likes to learn lessons
from cases of scientists
being tricked and this was a classic
case of a telescope in australia picking
up these short blasts of radio waves
and thinking you know these could be
weird bursts of radio light from deep
space what's ex
what could possibly be causing them we
should study these and then getting
pulled up short
by this idea of no we're probably just
detecting some weird terrestrial
interference um in the radio regime
there's all sorts of things that can
cause
radio interference um wi-fi networks can
cause them um spark plugs in
cars in internal combustion engines can
create little blasts of radio light so
we're completely familiar with
terrestrial interference and this team
at parks
went about trying to explain ways that
you could
produce a blast of radio waves from
something garden variety on earth
and my favorite part of this is that
they got sort of an early hint
that there was a problem because they
realized these things they were
detecting that they nicknamed
peritons it's a mythical creature that
looks like one thing but it's something
else
uh they were clustering around the
lunchtime hour and
space is weird but space doesn't care
when lunch is in australia
so that was kind of the first clue and
then they sort of fussed with microwaves
trying to see while microwave produces
radio interference we know
can we get a microwave to make a
peritone and they couldn't because they
were being very good careful scientists
they were
placing a ceramic mug of water in a
microwave they were letting it run for
10 seconds
waiting opening it and then not seeing
anything and when they've started using
the microwaves like you know impatient
hungry people
where you let it count down and before
it gets to the end you go and screw it
and open the door then they were able to
make a peritone and it explained
most of the blasts of radio light that
they were getting but not all of them
some of them were real and today these
are a class of objects called fast radio
bursts
that we still don't really understand
and that people are still studying but
we had to
find and explain the microwaves and kind
of get the microwave data out of the
pile
before we could study the real science
of real radio bursts from space instead
of from
the break room very good and the next
kind of question that might be allied
with it or not
is why are these telescopes located in
specific
locations uh can't they be used
essentially anywhere
if they're uh if they're just looking up
at the same night sky that's shared
around the world
yeah so the location of telescopes
matters a great deal because
much like with the peritons we want to
make sure we're detecting things from
space and nowhere else
so for the type of light that we see
with our eyes we want telescopes in very
remote
places and we want to be in places where
the atmosphere is very still so the air
quality is nice and crisp
we want to be in places where you're
getting very little light pollution
where the weather is good
so that you can you know actually use
the telescope on night to night instead
of being
stopped by clouds or the immense
thunderstorm that we have raging here in
seattle there's a reason we don't fill
telescopes in seattle
um for radio telescopes you want them
very far from radio interference
you also like to put them in places
where you can get a great view of as
much as the sky
as possible um this is why not all
telescopes but a lot of telescopes are
built near
the equator and then a place like the
south pole you get access to half the
sky but you get access all the time
and you're in this wonderfully remote
dry perfect place
for observing so where we put telescopes
on earth is
actually really critically important
especially when you
get into what type of light you want to
detect
and then i have a question uh that i
will use my
host prerogative to ask you you talk a
lot about the book towards the end
and i want to share some of the uh some
of the material that you provided for
book clubs and other readers which is
just so helpful another thing that you
did i wish i did in my book
easy to remember name a 2009 ip which is
a
thought to be a supernova maybe it's not
it was a nova and
it was discovered in 2009 and then you
talk about it uh
and its behavior in 2012 and now we are
here in the end
gloriously the end of 2020 hopefully it
will be coming soon without much more
uh drama but who knows supernova could
go off again
and that could cause more problems and
maybe that's likely and given everything
that's happened so far but anyway
you talk about your heart sinking when
another group
sort of was was horning in on your
racket so to speak
uh i want you to talk about that what
does it feel like how
how does competition drive uh
discoveries in astronomy we you talk
about even people hacking
you know the hubble uh twitter account
to see what people are looking at to
gain an unfair advantage
talk about uh competition in astronomy
and then
personalize it and how it felt to you
when you were potentially scooped and
and and how that felt i think that
healthy competition in science is
excellent i think it helps keep people
honest
um i think that having multiple people
working on a problem and taking their
own approach can only make the
eventual answer to the problem better um
but this is another case where we don't
want to forget that scientists are
people and scientists are human
and when you imagine making a great
discovery nobody imagines making the
great discovery
second you kind of want to be first and
the trick is that balancing act between
doing the work
first and doing the work well and where
i get disappointed a lot of times in
science and i think we
still see it happening is the rush to be
first can sometimes lead to sloppy
science
or rushed science and this is where i
think it's great that there's multiple
teams working because we can catch each
other's mistakes
i've absolutely had people catch
mistakes that i've made in my research
and been glad um i talked about those
thorn [ __ ]
objects that we were studying before and
there's been multiple papers saying you
know maybe you didn't find a thornjitkov
object maybe you were wrong maybe you
made a mistake
and i want those people to keep writing
those papers because if we were wrong we
should know
and we'd like to find out what we
actually found and if we were right then
we need to try and poke at the discovery
as much as possible and make sure that
we're certain
so philosophically you want there to be
like you want competition and you want
people to strive for better science
um there is the disappointment of like
oh could i have worked a little harder
could i have been a little more careful
could i have
done this work first if i'd just been a
little better at this or if i'd been a
little faster
um and i do remember the disappointment
of seeing another team doing what looked
like the exact same work that we were
doing and we'd had no
idea that it was happening because
you've worked so hard on something and
then you see it sort of scooped out from
under you and this is
the term scooping but i think that it's
an interesting line to draw this comes
up a few times in the book that there's
a line between
competition that makes us all better at
what we do
in competition that ends with people
sniping out one another with research
that really gets rushed out and kind of
thrown into the press before it's ready
or research that gets
sort of done in the service of being
first rather than in service of being
right
there is this massive scramble the first
time we detected both gravitational
waves
and electromagnetic radiation from an
object that i think
ended in wonderfully careful scientific
papers
but like the political tale of
how that happened is practically a book
on its own so
i think when people say oh you you need
to like totally remove
like interpersonal politics from science
again you can't because science is done
by
people and you have to keep in mind what
drives someone and whether it's like
pure scientific curiosity or also a
little bit of like now i get to be in
the news
and recognizing that i think is
important when we
understand why we do what we do
absolutely i i look at your
work and uh i am mostly jealous of only
one thing
which is that uh sofia observation so
i'm showing sophia i've been showing
sophia in the box
so i'm a pilot uh a private pilot i
don't work for the airlines yet
uh but uh but i love airplanes i love
flying and i'm an astronomer so what
better place for me to do it and
one of my friends uh who's a professor
here um
karen sandstrom and and others have used
of course used sofia flown on it
i'm like can i be your graduate student
uh please karen
uh but but anyway um so what what is it
like what are these uh
besides the majestic image of a plane
flying with a giant hole in its side
uh what what what kind of impact do
instruments like that have
on the work that you do i am
so i first learned about sofia thanks to
jim elliott
and then years later when i was getting
ready to write this book realized that i
wanted to learn more about what it was
like
to use it and i came at it from a sort
of
just experience perspective i actually
wound up using sofia for my research
because
this gets back to a question that
another one of your listeners asked
which was how do you use
multi-wavelength observations
there's data that we can only get right
now by flying up above most of the water
vapor
in our atmosphere and working from the
stratosphere and there are wavelengths
that sophia is uniquely capable
of getting and we won't really have that
capability until james webb launches in
2016 so
until then i think sofia fills an
important sort of role
in our research and being able to access
wavelengths like that and take the data
that sophie is capable of
is great because it gives us another
piece of the puzzle and you get to fly
on a
plane into the stratosphere like how how
fun can it get
so i i loved my chance to learn about
sophia and talk to the crew members
and then fly on it and it's one of my
favorite experiences that i wrote about
in the book
yeah i could do not it's such a
phenomenal instrument and you know who
knows maybe
maybe he'll take me on as i get my
second phd someday um
i want to wind down with some of the uh
remaining questions but also
uh kind of uh go a little bit lower tech
and and sort of how you start off the uh
the book is sort of this
um this homage to a naked eye observing
and it reminds me of a question one of
my listeners who's actually an author
naturalist his name is bernie taylor
and he has a theory that women were the
first astronomers
because of their monthly cycles so to
speak
that they would notice correlations
maybe uh you know confusing them or
saying con
you know confirming them as a sort of uh
responsible or connected to some way
the astronomical periods of the moon and
another daily phenomenon i don't know if
you've ever heard this
uh you know you talk about the last star
gazers but maybe women were the first
star gazers according to him
i don't so i'm hesitant of getting too
far into anything that could look like
you know evolutionary psychology
but i do but i do think that the idea of
naked eye astronomy stretching
far back much further back than i think
people imagine
is an important thing to keep in mind
because i think a lot of people think
about the first astronomer and they
think of like galileo and you know like
the
outfit with the little telescope on the
balcony pointing it up at something
and the history of astronomy goes back
so much further than that
and if you just look at for example
things like indigenous astronomy
and the sort of storytelling aspect of
how we studied the night sky and how we
passed down what we knew about the night
sky
like this is such a fascinating detail
of
how we studied the way that the night
sky changed with time
and how we used it to do everything from
you know
keep track of the seasons keep track of
when things grew
um navigation was an immense part of it
like if you want to look at some of the
most astonishing astronomers in history
you can look at
polynesian navigators and the like
petrifyingly enormous trips that they
were able to take
through an area as hostile as the
pacific ocean just by knowing the sky by
heart
um so when i think back to the first
astronomers i think of things like this
um there's a really cool detail of
astronomy
that didn't actually make it into the
last stargazers but that i
love because when you think about um
early astronomy you maybe think of it in
terms of storytelling and mythology and
just oh look at the pretty stars we made
shapes in them
and the early observers were actually
discovering really interesting things
about the night sky so aboriginal
astronomers had identified
ada carina and its variability in the
1800s they'd recognized
for a very long time that betelgeuse is
a variable um we've been studying the
weird variability of
betelgeuse very recently but aboriginal
astronomers knew about this
long long before we had things like
light curves and
computer day and like you know digital
data on these stars
so when i think of the first astronomers
i like thinking back
to sort of the full breadth of knowledge
that we can get on astronomy and really
think about what we can gain from all
these different areas
yeah and i'm showing here of course a
naked eye observation that was made
of the of the moon going in front of
another astronomical object the sun
uh that you lead off the the book with
and your
adventures as a professional astronomer
witnessing an event in 2017
and what that meant to you and kind of
how you lost your mind
uh as did i witnessing the exact same
event a few hours later in south
carolina talk us
through that and then we'll close with a
couple more questions from the audience
and uh
and i would really very much like to
hear uh
how the eclipse of 2017 impacted you
as a professional and just as a person
oh i loved i i'd wanted to see a total
eclipse for years but i just never
gotten the chance to go
um one thing i loved about it is that i
got to see it with my whole family
and with a bunch of colleagues because
we all went out to uh wyoming to see
this total eclipse
i'd heard all these descriptions about
how beautiful it was and
this like peaceful moment of like
feeling the moon and the earth and the
sun align and how lovely it would be and
i
once we hit totality i just went ah
there's so much to see there's so much
to do this is so cool like i don't i
don't have a lot of chill
and none of it was on evidence during
the uh during the total eclipse
but it was so memorable to me to watch
the lead-up to it and
see i was in a giant field on a golf
course with a bunch of amateur
astronomers and watch
how many people were getting sucked in
by an astronomical event
um during the total eclipse itself i was
so excited to see things like the solar
corona because i researched the outer
layers of stars and stellar winds
and i was looking at it with my eyes
like i wasn't looking at
data from it or a spectrum of it or
observations through a telescope like i
was
staring at a phenomenon that i study
which i just thought was so cool
and i loved seeing how it hit the news i
loved that for a day or two
astronomy was getting people excited all
over the country
um it's actually something that i think
about now
in the context of the last stargazers
and in the context of the book coming
out
in the middle of the pandemic because
people will ask you know why does
astronomy matter why do we care what
does it really give to us
and we've seen the power of a shared
experience
at unifying people through something
like the pandemic which is sadly pretty
tragic and
a really difficult time for a lot of
people but you see the
shared experience of people all over the
planet going through this together
and astronomy to me gives people that
same global scale shared experience but
through joy
so something like sharing the experience
of looking at a solar eclipse
or observing that naked eye comment that
came by back in july
um or seeing the first picture that we
took of a black hole or hearing about
potentially habitable planets like
these are some these are things that we
can share as humans and
i think getting a little reminder of
there's a shared human experience
regardless of what else we might be
going through and
sometimes it can be something sad like a
pandemic sometimes it can be something
happy
like a reminder of how the universe
works and
that to me is really something that i
think astronomy adds and contributes to
humanity
and then speaking of the moon and
speaking of uh your
uh your kind of enviable position of
being able to do many different things
in astronomy
uh again another question is if an
observatory is built on the moon would
professor levesque
want to be the first person to take a
trip there on the maiden voyage to the
moon observatory
yes um but just a cool fact i'm like
again i can't stop myself from doing
this with like did you know
but something i read about in the book
is that we actually have put an
observatory on the moon
before and i'm amazed that more people
don't know about this um
we sent an ultraviolet telescope to the
moon on board apollo 16
built by this amazing astronomer and
engineer named george carruthers
um he's actually the guy that invented
basically the ultraviolet camera and the
ability to capture uv images
and he built that and put it into this
little like three inch telescope
that was used on apollo 16 by john young
and charlie duke
so i love the idea of a permanent
observatory on the moon with you know
the
heaps of funding that we will surely
have for scientific research
and space exploration um but i like
pointing back to that first example of
space-based and moon-based astronomy and
saying well we need to do more of that
because we did it before and it was
really fascinating so
i would love to go back and then lisa
locke a friend of mine
and yours potentially she asked you have
any information on why the infrared
telescope spica was
cancelled um i
don't unfortunately so spika was the
space infrared telescope for cosmology
and astrophysics um
my understanding it's still oh it
recently got cancelled as um a candidate
for
a isa mission so i unfortunately wasn't
involved with the project and can't say
a lot about
why it was canceled um i know that we'll
have some really excellent infrared
space telescopes already planned between
james webb
and the roman space telescope um
i'm always of the mind that the more
telescopes we can put up the better but
i also know that hard decisions need to
be made
between multiple different types of
observatories so
hopefully there will be more coming out
from the folks who made that decision
about why it happened because i know it
was canceled pretty recently right like
in the past week or two yeah well
hopefully we'll learn more emily uh i
want to thank you so much
uh our guest has been uh professor dr
emily leveck
of the university of washington
astronomy department author
of a phenomenal book the last stargazers
i'm going to be posting my review i
listened to the audiobook i read the
hardcover
i downloaded the kindle so i've got all
formats it's beautifully
bound published your publisher should
receive a lot of credit for such a
wonderful book
of course your agent or co-editor help
helping
assistant editor jeff shreeve our mutual
friend deserves some credit and you
thank him in the acknowledgments
there's a guide for readers groups and
discussion groups in the back of the
book
i'm putting a link to emily's lovely
tedx talk from
earlier this year at given at berkeley
and other resources will be in the show
notes that'll be forthcoming i want to
thank you so much emily for your time
on this rainy thundery weather at least
far up north uh
from where i sit thank you so much for
having me
great pleasure take care bye